damit der hollywood wasser hat vorjahr
murats ernsthaft der zettel ist noch im
bild-test mitlesen
nachher merken die blätter sind wir so
weiter weg
seitdem schweigt sich die ja dann muss
ich mir sorgen
lesen okay aber warum ist hirn zettel
sagst du jetzt rasant verließ mein gott
ich mal papierverschwendung nun dass
damit was nicht vergessen so klein auf
so ein riesen papier
das hat damit habe ich vom land
ausgeschlossen auch das ist nicht
schlimm ich mache die rückseite manchmal
eine wunschliste für weihnachten sein
kann kein weihnachten müssen deutlich
mehr gewesen muslime aber ich habe hier
meine wunschliste machen halo gewünscht
hatten
wir haben hier eine richtige
materialschlacht für unseren coole
nespresso clubs diese materialien ist
jetzt ziemlich viel aus aber habe alles
zu hause richtig an alles zu hause ja ok
mal als 1000 back genau
also fangen wir an hier haben mir zucker
das zucker
wir haben schon sagen wie viele baustoff
weder den zettel
was sind das immer größere in die hand
mein gott massen normale eier
es ist wenn du irgendwo in australien
busch sachen biss hat normale eier
können auch straußeneier seien dann
immer zu hause gibt's ein austragen
juni gibt es in afrika und in das
rahmenthema bild kein stein natürlich
jetzt helfen wenn sie einmal in
australien gibt straßen
ehrlich ich finde den leuten gar nicht
vorstellen dass mit profis sind
wir sind zwar kein das werden
gemacht seit jahren durchgezogen macht
so ablesen
okay okay also wie gesagt wir fangen
jetzt an mit den zutaten hier ist eine
richtig coole materialschlacht aber ich
mir sicher die hat mir zu daher alle zu
hause habe ich recht ja ja so ich finde
wir müssen auch gar nicht so
professionell tun die leute wissen das
nicht packen können deswegen immer prinz
erholen und was steht hier drauf und
zwar wir haben hier sechs eier von
glücklichen hühnern
ich sag ich ganz ganz wichtig natürlich
die persönliche persönlich ja genau ich
kenne die hühner persönliche weise von
die geboren wurden
so dann haben wir 130 gramm zucker war
diese zu weißer zucker tschuldigung dann
haben wir 100 gramm braunem zucker dann
habe eine prise salz dann haben wir hier
ein teelöffel pro karton kameras was
ganz ganz cool ist etwas neues das ist
ein was ist das das ist konto cup holen
extrakt genau aus der tonkabohne weiß ja
schon mal in der kabine gesessen und ich
habe sie schon gesehen
herrlich auch schon gegessen ich hab
doch schon das abgemacht mit den marken
gemeint war ist unklar da müsst ihr
aufpassen bei funk ab hier kann es nicht
passieren so wie tom katar ist dieses
dieser stoff kommen drin und wenn du zu
viel kombinieren kann ist natürlich
schäden verursachen deswegen hab ich
schon gedacht hast du schon gegessen als
system als kind mit tom kawara gezogen
auch hier ist ganz was ganz was cool ist
schmeckt richtig genial
dann haben wir hier 200 gramm sondern
könnten rapsöl und eine sonnenblumenöl
oder und sonnenblumenöl nehmen genau und
beim öl ist es ja so es gibt ja auch
schlechte und es gibt gute fette und gut
gefüllter
schlechter kann man ernst tschuldigung
100 gramm espresso und und zwar espresso
100 gramm
dann gehen wir kurz an die kommission
kam espresso ich zeige jetzt nicht mehr
was korpus mit j
jetzt waren wir eine kurze
produktplatzierung ich sage nicht was es
ist ein wenig lesen glaube ich sollte
doch ich bin zu lesen was ist ganz ganz
lustig ist ich wollte gerade was einer
kaffeemaschine erklären und dann kommt
grad der benni rhein gelaufen bin wir
müssen da hinten oder zeit mal ganz kurz
kommen mit sehr wenig es ist wirklich
ein absolut zufall dass jetzt gerade
rein läuft und zwar gleich ganz kurz
vorstellen ist es benny genau ist ja
unser benny ist ein freund von uns
besorgt bin jetzt vier grad abu dhabi
cent wesen freund kannst du mir dass
meine geschichte lebendig ist
vertriebsleiter noch bei bosch und ist
für unsere gegend hier zuständig ist ein
guter freund von mir und das ganz ganz
lustige ist der baby boomer türsteher ja
dann wird auch das sagt ja und zwar da
war damals hieß es noch treffpunkt wurde
spaß das war nicht immer so sagt sagt
und ich bin ihnen dies vorangekommen
ohne spaß mich haben sie immer raus
geladen das wundert uns möge ich bin
rein gelaufen was haben die gesagt er
war eine riesenschlange und ich war ganz
ganz hinten in der schlange
okay war ganz hinten der schlange dann
macht er so hey du da ja da der da
hinten ganz hinten abgelassen hätte ich
damals nicht die disco reingelassen und
und dann gab's damals karten durch die
die dienst auf diese unseren leuten es
regnet ja war es sehr lustig und so auch
eingelassen habe jemand damals immer
probleme gehabt in der disco rein zu
kommen weil irgendwie ist so lustig
jetzt kommt türsteher bist du ein
bisschen geschrumpft ich habe mich
größer ich habe die schuhe aus anstehen
sondern ich habe natur sandalen fertig
angezogen werden
wir haben immer aussortieren nach der
größe und bist du klein es ging ja und
wie gesagt die leute haben angst vor da
drin
das hat so gar nicht so viel falsch
machen das heißt also diese geldbeutel
von 1 bis 90 reinstecken der tasmanische
teufel die osmanische und heute darf
nicht sein
aber es war ohne sparen ich wollte man
immer was wissen ja jetzt kommst du bist
echt ein türsteher gewesen jetzt muss
ich jetzt wissen
benny war das uns verfolgt ich hatte
immer das gefühl dass ich als als
ausländer
ich sage ausländisch aus und natürlich
auch aus langdorf benachteiligt wurde
jetzt mal ganz ganz ehrlich weil die
besteht mit der in der branche drin ist
es wirklich so dass dann schon sinn wenn
du sagtest halt hier klein aus und ein
bisschen links hat sich mit mir hat
nicht nur damit ist er links abbiegen
hat nichts mehr im auswärtsduell fragen
warum wir nicht reingekommen ich habe
doch alles gehabt
53 müssen weiter backen wenn beide
schoben dankeschön
wir machen weiter und der kaffeemaschine
gehen leider sind nicht bemerkt es hat
nichts daran gelegen dass ich okay ganz
kurz schuldig es hat länger gedauert
mein gott des monats fünf minuten so
folgendes das ist eine kaffeemaschine
falls es noch nicht wusste und hier
kannst du es tresor auslassen und die
kanzel pressesprecher nicht alle
einstellen
und da kannst du auch die menge um 60
millimeter ist ein espresso groß größer
kann sie sich einstellen drückst du hier
drauf wir brauchen 100 werden naja du
musst 250 oder geht nicht größe 52
richtig ging ja richtig gerechnet und
sorgte zu färben
wo war ich einmal so es kommt nichts 20
richtig 250 m2
doch das geht auch aber ich weiß nicht
wie mein gott dann habe ich mir gedacht
ein großes handbuch ich aber ich weiß
schon ziemlich viel über die
kaffeemaschine ich super jetzt kommt das
wichtige beim espresso ist meiner
meinung nach temperatur und der schaum
es muss ein richtig cooler schaum drin
sein
klar sie ist bei diesen brechen jetzt
nicht weil es ist beim kleinen becher
noch besser sogar es geht noch ist
lustig ist immer wenn ich an die
kaffeemaschine geht ohne spaß passe
immer nur mir kein kaffee drin und kein
wasser
ich muss jedes mal das team auf das ist
gleich auch wenn man aufs klo gehen
erstmal plätze pro kilowatt ein ruder
masala am tag - cooles nutzen daher wenn
du das auch so
da wasser zu einer million das eisen
streit ist gleiche wenn der physik ist
immer die umrechnung von 9,1 doch das
ist immer 9,7 irgendwas 100 meter in 100
gramm aus es kommt auf die dichte an
alles kannst du natürlich wissen weil du
nicht ganz dicht sind 200 gramm mehl 100
gramm oder 100 milliliter deutschland
vorher nicht zugehört das problem ist
folgendes gül hat eine stärkere dichte
deswegen scheint öl auch immer oben
verstehen was ich meine manches leichter
an zu hause genau du nicht okay da war
weiter unsere in der zeit wo wir einfach
nur die zutaten zeigen meine frau schon
drei kunden gewarnt
das ist ein riesenproblem familie ja
okay dann aber hier 200 gramm mehl das
wird wahrscheinlich 405 sein
ja und du gesagt typ 08 15 kann es sei
denn du sieben für 12 oder okay dann
haben wir ein päckchen backpulver so
dann haben auf 50 gramm cacau genau
das finnische sba kakao und normaler
über cacau weil es bei kakao ist nicht
so süßlich der bug cacau ist nicht mit
zucker versetzt
ja kein es kriegt kein es also noch mal
richtig stimmt so dann haben wir 100
gramm schoko drops backfest okay so und
das war es dann
und jetzt schon an mit mit dem teig
richtig
ok und dann habe ich hier heute morgen
schon aufgeschrieben wie wir das machen
müssen das hat mich morgens schon müsse
aus dem gedanken spielen rezepte
entwickelt so heißt jetzt nimmer uns war
niemeyer zucker brauner zucker salz in
eine schüssel geben und das ist sonst
eher leise hat sich den rheinbrücken
sonst geht es mir besser jetzt machst du
warst in eier zucker fangen wir an
marijn zucker brauner zucker
ich versuche jetzt wirklich keiner sehen
weil ich eher brauner zucker und eine
karbon kann und die machen wir hier
zur und diese masse tut mir jetzt cremig
rühren genau was schön bisschen cremig
rühren aber noch ganz ganz ruhig alles
erstmal jetzt cremig rühren damit ist
eine homogene masse wird eine homogene
masse und danach immer noch espresso
langsam einräumt und zwar hier das öl
schön langsam und es ist ganz ganz
wichtig dass man wirklich die ein des so
ein held wie man es rein macht also ich
gehe nach der reihenfolge
das ist ganz wichtig beim marken map
pack ist wirklich eine sache da muss man
aufpassen
und warum ist es wichtig warum wir das
richtig rein rein machen sollte was ich
auch genau das ist nicht locker das blog
vergiss es mache nicht den espresso und
wer ist doch war da wenig warm sein
was kann passieren die eier könnten die
spieler werden kann dass ein land mit
vielleicht gewinnen dann kann es
gewinnen was ja bei dir ich auch schon
eines gewinnt ja was auch jetzt schon
auf den espresso von zwei saxo und es
riecht schon richtig nach
okay okay wenn man das gemacht haben
mehl und backpulver 1 gewinnen löffel
und ist okay salz auch mit rein perfekt
so nach dem muster als wird rein gemacht
haben machen wir und backen ohne mehl
und backpulver und aktoren gemeinsam mit
mary ja okay dann machen sie mal
löffelweise ein level weiter kannst auch
machen das auch pol de mar haben
schneller
ok richtig ist absolut richtig erkannt
und dann geht es weiter und zwar steht
hier cacau 7 und mit schoko den teig
rühren nur kurz berühren
aber er schreibt über nachdem sie zu
lange
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so schön und es riecht richtig
gegenhalten
vorschriften
ich habe gerade probiert und es schmeckt
richtig lecker das war's dann probieren
auch tierisch wenig heißt es denn ja
also sozusagen du viel denn findet ist
macht der job schon alt mein gott da
könnte man ja ja du auch so
[Musik]
okay das coole ist jetzt ist es auch
ganz aber das ist etwas angst gekriegt
das kann ist das ganz ganz cooles und
zwar das ist also nennt sich nicht mehr
genau an einer hand und wir haben unten
den deckel dran und jetzt schon nämlich
das terrain schützen
das geht nur minuten deckel hast dann
ist man nämlich folgendes machen
so auch wenn im deckel habe ich neben
angeschüttet ich bin so doof zu arbeiten
sowohl jetzt machen den deckel bekommen
nein habe ich erkannt so und jetzt total
langsam rühren darf ich
und jetzt auch guck mal wie das aussieht
joschka hagemann ersten dreifachsieg
jetzt sieben aktiven lieben lieben so
und jetzt bin ich noch wenn du noch
etwas drin wäre kann man einfach den
deckel wieder drauf machen kannst
abstellen wirklich dreckig und wenn man
was drin ist das keine irgendwelche
ungeziefer oder oder irgendwelche leute
reinkommen so wie zum beispiel kann man
einfach den deckel drauf machen sagt weg
stellt hast du gesehen
genial auf jeden fall haben wir jetzt
noch die schoko drops die machen wir
jetzt auch langsam rein
[Musik]
so jetzt haben wir alles zusammen
gerührt und jetzt kümmert es eigentlich
die die backform einfetten schön
einfetten das ist eigentlich nicht so
wie eine gummi mit bodylotion eingecremt
das ist dann bist du ja hast du gemacht
aber okay und dann jetzt haben wir es
schön hier zu einer homogenen masse
gerührt jetzt machen auch folgendes
jetzt aber die backform hier und da gibt
es verschiedene google hochform das ist
jetzt zu einer gewissen modernere
kugelform bei google um vom bitte darauf
achten dass es wirklich eine coole
qualität ist das ist eine coole qualität
tickets nicht leider nichts es sind wir
hier das ist ein kokos und das ist ein
kokosöl und rapsöl genau schön
verspricht senkrecht halten und zack
wenn ich dann geht es raus hielt das
mittel steht so nennt sich das mittel
steht das wusste ich gar nicht
das reicht auf jeden fall
und nachdem man das gemacht haben 170
grad ober unterhitze aber auch gar nicht
verheizen hätten wir uns vor heizen
vergessen ganz kurz getragen oder
zeitreise nochmal zurück und ich mag
lassen
so jetzt im backofen und jetzt einfach
ober unterhitze 170° danke oder das
anklage und jetzt einfach zu schließen
war perfekt
[Musik]
jetzt hat man angemerkt hat gefragt
ich habe mal erklären sie erklären kann
warum wir zwei so gut auskommen darauf
dann anfangen zu erklären dass
unterschiede ziehen sich haben
gegensätze ziehen sich an
ja aber ich glaube zwar dass ich nicht
dann habe ich weniger erklärt dass man
mit sally groß juni groß
murat kaya dann seine hübsche hübsch
morath heran so lehrerin intelligent
intelligent jetzt haben den chor im
vorgeheizten backofen schule in den
backofen als zwar schön genießen
und jetzt immer den kuchen und chemie im
backofen rein sagt halten gerade wir
sind erstmal die vom rhein genauso bevor
jetzt diese richtig coole masse in die
backform rhein geben die wir eingeleitet
haben noch ganz viel was zu beachten wir
haben ja schoko drops reingemacht
und da muss man echt aufpassen dass die
schoko drops nicht auf einer stelle sind
die werden auch runter sinken
ja weil alles so schwer ist ist unter
sinken und deswegen machen wir ein
ich mache das ist
das was wir hier zu zweit machen können
normale menschen auch alleine machen
wollen nur gerade dann will ich nur
sagen wenn wir nicht immer werden wenn
wir schon am ersten tag pleite und damit
viel zu langsam sind
aber es ging uns sind braucht weile
kennt es nicht das wort pudding braucht
weingut den us open schon ganze bude und
die technik die bücher wie so ein bomber
tja jetzt machen wir auch so ich mache
am besten hier
warum ist dann macht das nicht sonst
rutschen die trupps runde
ok jetzt nehmen wir diese form tun sie
aufs backblech und dann schieben sie bei
170 grad in den backofen und ungefähr
nach wie viel minuten vor 50 minuten
also knapp eine stunde
politisch tot ist ach gott sicherheit
wer sie also kann es kleine ford 55 bis
60 minuten in den backofen schieben und
dann auch immer wieder die städtischen
eigenbetriebe baghlan
die stäbchen probiert vormann rausnimmt
genau dass die stäbchen probe ding das
war auch damals wurden enttäuscht waren
weil das stäbchen probe dass dann
schluss dran stand war ja dann meint
oder meint ein händler
ja auf jeden fall nämlich das ist blech
und schiefer backofen reiten können
das lustige ist ja ich frage mich immer
die menschen alleine packen können wir
müssen alles zu zweit machen weil beim
bei einigen ixia ist lustiger ersten
erschreckt einige ihrem zelle weniger
wir werden pflanzen
ja genau bei mir so sein sagt maintaler
wachsenden marktes blechdosen bekommen
die form reinstellen
da sind deine hand frei
du bist dann jetzt so wie du aussiehst
der film soll jetzt ist er drin
und jetzt 55 bis 60 minuten es gehört
der in war ein richtiges vakuum gezogen
kennt sich aus mit vakuum kennt sie aus
hast ja auch eins wahnsinn 2 50 bis 60
minuten und einer stelle
wir können sagen eigentlich natürlich
und zwar passt auf dem auf dauer aber
naja 55 x 55 weiter so ganz gut mal bei
55 gut so und jetzt einfach statt alles
braucht gar nicht mehr wahnsinn sachen
gibt es wunder der technik wahnsinn aber
gespannt wann du kannst du nicht lesen
das heißt ja nicht gelernt aber ich kann
dieses mal beibringen
ich war zeit haben im zeigt stelle es
geht und wir räumen so lange aufrecht
ich hoffe ich mache dich weg alles klar
während wir wären wir auf den kuchen
warten
das ist auch mal sehen neben hätte mir
schon aufräumen wir tun alles spielen
auch mit der hand spielen
ja und ich bin ich dein räumen ja und so
sieht es aus wenn man wenn man neben dem
dreh neben der backzeit was sinnvolles
macht richtig krieg haben wir anhand
tust daheim auch spülen sondern ehrlich
ja ich mache das nur vor der kamera
du wachst auch privat bugs zu ehrlich
jetzt
man sieht ja auch ich mir auch gut für
meine frau vielleicht auch eine fitness
youtube drin wäre ich habe gehört wie es
studio deutsch sagt man auch das ist ja
wasser an den rhein getragen vermutlich
so überflüssig wie würde ich bin halt
ich hätte eh nichts bei dir ich tue
snackautomaten reparieren deswegen waren
eine frage hast in deinem leben schon
mal ist das für sport gemacht bist du
ein sport ist eigentlich ein sportlicher
typ hat mich auch gewundert als
fußballer so gerade zu stellen ist dies
jetzt auch mach dich fertig
okay aber wein und kuchen tennis haben
wir ein endspiel der ball gekonnt ins
netz
es ist also könnte ich doch ich glaube
uns mal golf spielen kann ich mein handy
sein das wir kennen das ist laut bank
[Musik]
nach springe ich hab vorher reingeschaut
mache ich noch gedacht hätte ein
bisschen mehr zeit nehmen sollen habe
aber vergessen haben aber vergessen dass
der teig dass der kuchen noch hoch geht
deswegen der braucht er platz
ja richtig das dual screen gefügt du
hast du bist nicht hochgegangen war was
sich seinen weg das gebiss klein
geblieben
du bist klein und gehst jetzt nach vorne
raus ich bin groß gemacht groß bis klein
und ich bin hübsch du ganz kurz noch das
ist nur spaß ja das ist mir wir denken
uns ja was macht man wirklich nicht
mobbing ist nichts tolles nein ganz ist
das richtig bescheuert was macht mir
wirklich nicht unter freunden müssen
eltern ist dafür so scherze machen da
ist ja auch keiner beleidigt oder genau
das ist auch du bist auch ich beleidigt
ich meine du hast ja manchmal manchmal
ich habe schon weiche kern ja manchmal
gehst du zu weit aber ich vielleicht ein
weiches hilfe aber den gleichen kern mal
machen sich dann heraus und lässt mal
ehrlich wenn du bist du fertig macht
dafür nicht vertraue übergehen wir
bieten ja noch nein möglich das machen
wir mit nicht unter freunden wenn man
sich gut kennt und wo man nur spaß ja
nur spaß es ist wahnsinn
okay ich habe die stäbchen probe gemacht
und das problem ist einfach die minis
weg weil weil sie nicht weg weil ihr
wert sich glauben würde geschichte ein
anruf bekommen die grünen gerade eben
und zwar das heizöl werk gekommen
ja und dann musste er gehen weil er
krieg heizöl und deswegen ist weg
deswegen gehe ich jetzt an den kuchen
den hole ich jetzt aus dem backofen raus
und dann guck mal wie er aussieht
meine frau ist auch dadurch christoph m
das ist es mal ohne spaß jetzt ich darf
das eigentlich sagen aber das ist auch
gerade aus als hätte dass er sieht da ja
ich es echt schade dass es so aussehen
muss der steigt er immer ein bisschen
hoch okay das hat mir immer das problem
dass kuchen ins rad fahren immer draußen
weder dann so heißt das heißt aus dem
back dann ist ruhe und dann steigt er
hoch oben reißt deswegen haben wir das
soll das wusste ja dass die
luftzirkulation dienst seien gleichmäßig
da passiert nicht aber in solchen bank
okay so genau
also das heißt es nicht cool aus wird
sagen wir die typische kirmes in der
hand ist kein döner messer das ist ein
brotmesser kuchen und brotmesser genau
und das brotmesser hat immer einen
wellenschliff und dann gibt es einen
freud
warum hatten keine ahnung dass hat einen
wellenschliff nach vorne und zurück weil
die meisten brotmesser gehe nur in eine
richtung dann schneidest du die eine und
die andere reißt du da und deswegen hat
der vor und zurück ein mensch musste ich
natürlich habe sie extra ghr gehabt sie
nur getestet so und dann habe ich da
habe ich ein ganz besonderes freuen und
zwar den hendrik und zwar hat er mir mal
gezeigt und gesagt man tut nicht drücken
sondern schneiden richtig so lieber
hinrich wenn das fazit dank rast ist ja
richtig cool ich glaube dass extra so
konzipiert die backform die gibt es
nicht bei uns leider nicht dass das wenn
es ab schneidig genau das messenger
lange genug das heißt du kannst hier und
da ansetzen und einfach schneiden wird
gerade so
echt toll für mich für dich schatz denke
soll jetzt kommt ja eigentlich kommt ja
eigentlich ja
der schwierige partner kann dass sally
so jetzt nämlich das ding hier einfach
was oben drauf
hey hammer passt auch wissen was jetzt
ist jetzt doch jedes bully spaß wissen
was jetzt machen wollte ich bin so der
hammer ich wollte es einfach nehmen und
so drauf machen
grassmann da merkt man echt schlaue frau
irgendwie sieht es aus ich sehe aus wie
kung fu panda wenn ich jetzt mal reichte
es eine dumme idee
ich will mich nicht eigentlichen weiß
gar nicht will
ich habe ich weiß glaube ich es machen
das ok herunter so wahnsinn jetzt hab
ich noch mal die frage an dich ja du
jetzt zu klopfen
also habt ihr so wie ich geschrieben
habe gefettet und gemailt ja also ich
habe sie gerettet gemailt haben sie
nicht ja aber das ist aber das ist der
wahnsinn frau mit keine haftung also
normalerweise müsste jetzt echt gut
darf ich noch etwas fragen ich hab einen
backofen genommen bringt das was
verwendet es abkühlen lässt und dann
sich er sich zusammenzieht und wenn's
kalt haben und man kann auch in ein
feuchtes tuch drauflegen das kann zu
machen und dann ehrlich jetzt und es
bringt etwas okay und jetzt kann jetzt
also ohne minute okay aber ich weiß was
passiert das ist ein schock zieht sie
zusammen also und ein feuchtes tuch
darüber lägen über die backformen ich
möchte die backform ist noch warm und
klopft ein bisschen okay ich glaube dass
die reichen oder okay wenn ich hier so
gut passt kommt das gras fraß
ich habe das feuer erschaffen dieses wie
krass testing aussieht krass oder
viele leute packen auch in silikon
formen und da möchte ich das so sagen
darf ich ja ganz kurz wir dürfen bei uns
im backofen keine silikonform benutzen
weil silikon bestätigt gefahr dass es
aus dämpft sich über den sensor darüber
legt und dann punkteten unserer es ist
funktion nicht mehr und wenn du cool
backen kannst wenn du echt gut backen
kannst du brauchst auch eine silikonform
richtig genau weil die beste beste
wärmeleiter ist der beste wärmeleiter
ist immer eine backform ja jetzt blöd
ist aber auch mit silikon mehr euch das
übrigens nicht passiert ja auf jeden
fall richtig packen kann backteam
metallformen das richtig cool keramik
geht auch silikon musste ich ja immer er
geht auch silikon lustig sein wenn ihr
trotzdem silikon verwendet ist es gar
kein problem er lebte wahrscheinlich
durch die 20 jahre weniger aber gar kein
thema ja okay jetzt habe ich das gemacht
ich habe gesehen ein genieß
vorbeigekommen
der wird auch gleich einstimmen jetzt
haben sie den kuchen fertig und jetzt
würden wir ding machen eine glasur
drüber machen eine richtig coole show
klasse über unseren espresso google okay
wie gesagt der kuchen ist fertig und
jetzt möchten wir dass der kuchen und
mal richtig cool aussieht mit glasur
darüber machen und für die glasur
brauchen nämlich folgendes was brauchen
wir nicht sagt reimann kam das thüringer
töre und 30 gramm kokosöl kokosfett
genau gucken
genau und dann noch vielleicht aber es
ist je nach geschmack ungefähr 30 gramm
übungen am boden aber das zeigen wir
euch jetzt gleich wichtig ist dass man
richtig coolen schokoladenüberzug machen
so richtig schön schokoladenüberzug und
dafür gibt es ein paar tricks wir wissen
die tricks wir wenden sie sich schon
seit jahren an und es wird euch jetzt
mal ganz eigen jetzt gehen wir hier über
ok ihr denkt jetzt gleich ist es eine
produktplatzierung ist es auch so folgen
sie haben einen transporter von gvo den
3200 megawatt pro mit einem laser cut
edition kommen und herbert ok auf je
mehr wollen wir mal vollkommen haben ein
weiß gar nicht wo ich zwar die zahl
nicht mehr so mit dem kann man natürlich
auch hackfleisch machen wie kann man
sonst eher klein und allem drum und dran
wenn ich ein geniales teilen ohne strom
und es kann ja sein ist mal strom
ausfällt über jahre hinweg und dann kann
man es immer benutzen richtig so dann
nehmen wir hier erst einmal die
schokolade muss man jetzt ganz wichtig
aufteilen um ein drittel zwei drittel
wir haben sechs teile wenn man auf
teilten eintritte zwei drittel heisst es
zwei drittel sind 2 4 und 12 richtig ja
egal ob jemand immer hier die schokolade
und machen sie jetzt hier rein so genau
in hier nehme das rebootizer anders
investiert ist
vertrau mir dass ich glaubte etwas auf
das hat zwei dinge also jetzt was man
hier rein natürlich so siehst du das
war's sollten jetzt die nächsten
das ding
herrliche sting ach da ist ja ich bin ja
nicht herein werfen main kurz
ich war so auch geliefert warum wir
hilfe leben dran steht die hälfte
nebendran ich sagen okay aber ich glaube
ich weiß woran es liegt ja stimmt
slide dankeschön
man hat manchmal können wir vor wie zwei
kindergartenkinder was auch genau und
jetzt haben dieses thema leiser das
augen cooler trägt jetzt niemand diese
glasschüssel und machen sie hier drüber
so kann man es gibt glaube ja einfach
probleme genug
neben glauben genau hier bleibt aber
hier drin jetzt muss ich erklären ich
habe die zuschauer kommen jetzt hilfe
durch einander zuschauerin einander
konnten weil ich jetzt auch schon
gekommen
jetzt haben wir hier zwei drin der
schokolade drin jetzt tut es einfach das
holz ausgelassen auslassen ok er hat ein
bisschen rum gedrückt weil ich die töne
stolpern auslassen und diese hitze was
dieser topf machten sie energie steigt
nach oben
erhitzt die schüssel man merkt es schon
ein bisschen und jetzt wollte nur eins
sagen jetzt fragen sie gleich manche
menschen die oft ich auftrag eine frage
die oft kommt und zwar warum kein
parierten ein schokoladen man kennt doch
theoretisch auch nur in die mikrowelle
reinstellen und einfach schmelzen lassen
richtig genau und zwar ist es einfach so
wenn die schokolade nicht abbrechen
temperiert dann wird die glasur nachher
weiß richtig so und die ideale
temperatur bei schokolade ist temperiert
ist ungefähr bei 30 grad wir tun jetzt
diese zwei drittel schokolade
die lassen wir schon schmelzen und
kuvertüre tschuldigung und eine höhere
temperatur und dann tun wir einfach noch
diese kalte schokolade mit rein und tun
das nicht mehr erhitzen dann hat es
automatisch ein mittelwert und wer soll
bei 30 grad und 30 grad ist so ungefähr
die ideale temperatur damit die
schokolade ich weiß wird so jetzt warten
wir einfach weil wie heißt einfach ich
sage auch immer geduld ist das wichtig
ist wie viel bei dir wenn du 30
zentimeter größer werden die räume
größer
von gemischt werden und dann meter etwa
einen meter kürzer werden gewicht von
sechs oder sieben was ist bmw ich habe
nur drei jahren den weg alles lernen wir
warten jetzt einfach geduldig so die
kuvertüre ist jetzt zerlaufen das sieht
man auch richtig cool und jetzt machen
wir was rein und zwar ist das hier
kokosfett ich bin auch kokosöl nimmt das
hat zwei gründe was machen kokosöl sorgt
einmal noch von einem coolen glanz daher
und zusätzlich sorgt auch dafür dass es
die konsistenz der schokolade richtig so
der weiche konsistenz ist dass es
nachher so richtig schön drüber läuft
das machen jetzt rein sonders verrückt
jetzt auch mit rein
und während ich jetzt kommt nämlich der
ganze trick dass dieses schokolade
temperieren kommt ja nicht schlecht
jetzt nehme ich noch die rechtliche ein
drittel schokolade und jetzt für die
schokolade so ungefähr ich nehme also 49
grad haben genau für uns noch ein
bisschen da die schokolade 49 grad haben
die sich noch zu warm und damit sie
genau auf punkt auf 29 30 grad
herunterkühlt nehmen auch den letzten
drittel schokolade genau und können sie
jetzt dauert mitunter perfekt sonst muss
es so eine richtig coole flüssige
konsistenz haben und dann tun wir sie
gerade über den hafen laufen lassen und
vertrieblich cool aussehen perfekt des
perfekten sonst ein löffel darüber
machen ob die müssen ja auszuschütten
die migration aus der schüssel
ach so ich habe es noch gesagt
naja darüber ja ich hab ihm gesagt du
bist doch ich habe es mir gesagt ich
schwöre ich habe es ihm gesagt nein
wieso hast du ehrlich wir haben bisher
gerade mal ja
haben wir doch gemacht wenn ihr jetzt
haben wir ein haltet ist die locker 40
stolz natürlich eine solltest du gerade
in visegrad darin ja bitte sagen das war
es nicht
doch das ist viel zu klein jetzt beim
stand von 37 grad und locker
das nicht einfach so legt die somit rein
unterkühltes kommt übrigens weil ich
eins sagen diese fehler sind alle
gespielt damit ihr was lernt ok herzlich
und du wirst mit der nase riecht man wie
hart ein gott allein ist ja schon wieso
mache ich das ich so mache ich das mit
mir teilt das ist der super g fußwegen
3200 pro kreis passau was ich jetzt
mache oder dessen jetzt die bohnen jetzt
mal folgendes mit dem gv 3200 probstried
wing special edition eigentlich nur
dreimal ja dreimal machen soll
ich habe pulver draus gemacht jetzt
riecht noch mal ach das geht noch ein
extrakt krasses ab wo man sich wie
frisch gemalt wenn ich habe erzählt
könne gespalten und die aroma aromen
sind heraus gedrungen
die firma ansage sprecher bei der
tagesschau spielen wir machen jetzt
quartiere drüber drunter drüber dann
haben extra hier das hier auf anwender
auffangbehälter und das passt genau rein
und das kannst du kommen der schokolade
warum hat man aufwachen und zwar wir
haben auffangbehälter dass die
schokolade aufhängt und das machen wir
ja schon verlages aufgefangen da können
wir noch mal ein schmelzen und damals
jetzt kannst du raus nehmen und es ist
abgegrast
was sie einen auffangbehälter winter
draußen nicht ich habe könnte ich habe
keine angst
du bist doch auch einander nichts zu
verlieren die nachfrage ist bei der
bundeswehr war der einzige dem panzer
bedienen durfte nur ein vorwärtsgang und
drei rückwärts ging hat dankeschön so
und zwar sei die gruppe langsam cook
sowie der schatz der droge sagt marie
mit auf der stelle bleibe die
tarifstruktur raum sagt und wenn du
schon trägt warum soll ich da noch mal
drehen
bitte helft mir bitte schatzes ich
glaube das könnte uns bitte helfen
ja genauso habe ich gemeint dass es so
machen soll
naja sowohl dies auch mal aber ich habe
gedrängt der mein gott was wir machen
kann ich nicht böse sein ob kinder
schönes fünf minuten video mit monaten
juni oder ganz schön du hast ja toll
gemacht mit offenen haaren der kirche ja
ja die war gar nicht geplant weil
dahinter schreibt gerade ihr kochbuch
verstehe ich schon wir
ich komme gar nicht voran weil man tun
wenn man stammt ist kuvertüre zu machen
ja ok gesicht runter was dein gesicht
darunter kann man so ähnlich sein wie
jugendwartin einfach nicht ich glaube
dass das lag anzuheben gewissen ruhm
machen und es ist ein mittel über alles
und kann jetzt sagen kann auf jeden fall
ihr habt jetzt gelernt von bühne wie man
es nicht machen sollte moment wer hat
sie gemacht warum immer so kann man es
jetzt mal ohne spaß kann man das so
schneiden das aussieht als jetzt
funktioniert was wir machen wollten
schwierig sei die auf dem bild ist könnt
ihr so richtig sagen wow das war ein
wahnsinn wie das funktioniert hat ihr
seht es ist ganz ganz einfach gar keine
probleme gehabt macht es mir genauso
zuhause nach wie wir es gemacht haben
wir sind nicht überrascht wir wussten
dass es funktioniert sagt jetzt eine
tolle idee und zwar habe ich hier die
kaffeebohnen wo ich die zellkerne
zerstört habe damit die aroma
gespeichert damit die aroma knospen raus
können und dass ich mich noch diese
coolen dinger hier nie was auf uns
zukommt anhalt
[Musik]
übrigens nicht ganz ganz wichtig dass
hier ein hochlandkaffee nimmt weil der
hochlandkaffee wie viel aromatischer ist
wie flocke ja wieder tiefland kaffee und
außerdem ist ja fair bezahlt also genial
sich jetzt ist fertig jetzt mal kurz ein
foto und dann werden wir anrichten und
dann werden wir mal probieren oder oder
probieren lassen so mir jemand aus dem
team wohl volkan zer ist mit tochter
adia meyer tritt ein gemacht ich glaube
er weiß es nicht
das macht man nicht gerne gut das video
anprobierte und minuten um verfahren an
sich auch die gemüse auch als zu machen
muss jetzt freuen wir uns auf und machen
die fotos nicht alles sind und dann okay
[Musik]
so jetzt sind wir fertig haben die fotos
schon geschossen coole fotos gemacht
nennt sich das
du musst die deponie an die 10
das problem ist mein knie die zähne
macht dann fliegen die zähne raus das
ist das problem
so jetzt natürlich wäre es unfair wenn
wir alleine probieren würden wir uns
wirklich schmecken oder nun schmeckt es
immer auch wird sich so ist trotzdem
schmeckt uns weil wir wollen jetzt
zugeben dass mir mist gebaut haben ja so
jetzt haben wir zwei testpersonen und
zwar wir haben 100 menschen befragt und
haben dann ein schnitt aus der
schnittmenge geholt jetzt haben wir
einmal ein kind da und zwar die samira
halle samira und dann haben wir noch
eine erwachsene person und das ist ja
dennis denn es gehört auch zu unserem
team hier chef business marketing
officer denn es und dennis öfters bei
uns im team sehen die ihn hier noch
nicht beleidigt bin ja nicht recht warum
haben wir bereiten wir benötigen was
soll ich wieso auch die allianz gegen
bis aber wenigstens bist du noch für
mich okay kein problem damit ich war
schon immer der außenseiter
ok jetzt brauchen wir den kuchen aus das
ist ein cooler espresso google ökologen
genau das ist es
google schließt sie vor und da ging ich
bauch ist was auch ein google um ja so
ein problem jetzt mal ein espresso club
genau so espresso kugel coup
verbrauchsgüter hand ist - egal wo ist
da müssen wir das spülen und spülen
wir fliegen machen wir ohne gabel war es
noch nicht klick gemacht ja ja was macht
man eigentlich so dennis auch hinten
aber für mich ein kleines stück bitte
die kraft nicht wieder leisten weil
zwischen spruch entscheidet immer messen
sagt ja sagt samira probier mal und zwar
espresso kuchen kann ich sah mir ruhig
probieren welt das ist jetzt nicht so
schlimm
außerdem hast du heute noch kein red
bull gab deswegen ist es in ordnung für
heute aber es hat media pool ehrlich gar
nicht schmeckt dann dann sagt was
passiert denn jetzt kommt ehrlich nicht
weg mit ehrlichen ist ohne spaß hast du
schon flügen beigebracht hat das kannst
du lieber drauf wir sind keine chance
später ist es gewesen harry wohl aber
das ist ja jetzt mal ganz ehrlich magst
du das ehrlich ich würde es gut habe ich
gut gemacht machen wir mal ein stück den
gut gemacht
cool dhabi noch eine bitte stadtstaats
kümmern
meine frau ist da hinten darf ich meine
frau ist sein start wäre es noch möglich
ich finde ich echt fertig gibt es die
möglichkeit zum kuchen noch saftiger zu
machen
du kannst ihn noch trinken kaffee das
wäre ne coole geschichte passau ein
cooler typ noch cool also die coole idee
gemacht ist nach wenn er so auch seine
pakete junkie seit wie ich wenn der
kuchen aus dem ofen raus kommt noch mal
mit ein schönes präsent und richtig
genial
ok und was ich auch zeigen möchte ist
folgendes erste folge gesehen wir haben
die schokolade runter tropfen lassen und
das mir ihr seht dass wir ein
schwäbischer haushalt sind und alles
wirklich wieder verwerten
die schokolade die vor auf dem brett
gedruckt ist mit dem hammer noch rock
heroes gemacht und es geht auch jetzt
ganz einfach denn ist rocky road sense
gibt es übrigens ein rezept hier unten
findet ihr gerades rezepte rocky road
ist so eine coole resteverwertung weil
waste ist nämlich blöd problem meint ist
doch dennis für einen gefallen
in einem jahr schaut euch denn ist noch
mal an den grill und ja denn es wird bei
den ist kriegen wir auch noch fett ja ja
du merkst auch gerade genießt auch dick
im geschäft ist okay cool j dennis kuhl
hammer toll gemacht vielen dank für
zuschauen beim murats fünf minuten oder
mal mehr weil das keiner gesagt hat mit
fünf minuten kommt 66 minuten zu mir
leid hat richtig spaß gemacht
kommentiert bitte bereiten uns nicht
beleidigt die anderen ihr könnt es auch
tipps geben wir hatten uns nichts dran
wir machen das was uns spaß macht
richtig
ok macht's gut ganz liebe grüße kanada
person vergessen
diese texte die wir sollten uns zu
spielen die ganze zeit und diese
bösartigkeiten sind nur im fernsehen so
privat zu mir ganz netten ja bitte kein
mobbing beleidigung ist auch blöd ich
hoffe wir haben nicht über die stränge
geschlagen
wichtig ist einfach nur dass hier dass
wir spaß hat ja und wir mögen uns ja
macht's gut seid ihr für mich seid ihr
übrigens für mich oder verbindlich
schreibt darunter timo rath oder ok
[Applaus]